une saison qui démarre tout en douceur
le prise me fait sa rentrée le 28
septembre en mode cocooning
un premier rendez vous pour les enfants
de six semaines à deux ans et demi pour
cette nouvelle saison
dix dates sont destinés aux plus jeunes
on aura des choses aussi variées en
jeune public que par exemple un concert
de little rock story qui est un concert
participatif pour les familles à la
découverte de tout le répertoire du
rock'n'roll tati jambes ou marianne
james
voilà aussi avec un concert à la
direction des petits et plus du cirque
en ouverture de saison spectacle
simplicité sur terre
des spectacles pour tous les âges une
présentation regroupant tous les styles
du jazz du classique de la pop
en mars c'est zazie qui marque l'un des
temps forts en comptant son essentiel
marché
le tour
optics ekeren vérino et au qatar
ouedraogo elie semoun le prisme vous
invite à rire avec eux huit dates sont
dédiés à l'humour à la comédie le monde
caractérise cette saison sait où les
deux mots c'est osé rentrer osé venir
prendre des éléments culturels osé venir
au théâtre
oser venir au cinéma oser venir dans un
lieu culturel le prisme europe dans
cette logique extrêmement diverses
éclectique avec toutes formes de
spectacles cultures qui cohabitent voilà
à l'image aussi la population l'idée
c'est que chacun puisse trouver un
moment donné un rendez vous culturel et
artistique qui qui lui corresponde qui
lui donne envie de venir aux prises à un
moment donné de l'année et s'il ne
fallait pas rater une date au prisme on
vous oriente vers une oeuvre moliérisé
la machine de turing revient sur la
personnalité complexe d'alan turing
l'inventeur de l'ordinateur moderne